Possible evidence comes
from an FBI raid on an
Arizona warehouse in
January 2014.
Inside, agents discover
buckets of limbs and a
female head sewn onto
another body destined for
sale to the US military.
The FBI files on this
investigation have been
sealed, so there's no
real way to know which
bodies ended up at which
military bases and what
kind of tests they were
subjected to.
Human experimentation at
the base and the image
began decades ago.
A lot of work is
classified, but some
programs like Operation
Delirium, where US
soldiers were dosed with
PCP, sarin gas, just to
test the effects. Those
types of drills were
conducted at this
location.